[Musique]
bonjour à tous nous sommes à accra la
capitale ghanéenne a été choisie par la
banque africaine de développement cette
année pour y tenir ces assemblées
générales et en 2022 c'est
l'environnement qui est au coeur des
débats nous allons justement nous y
intéresser l'invasion des criquets
pèlerins l'érosion la sécheresse le
manque d'eau autant de fléaux qui
menacent déjà le continent dans ce
numéro grâce aux reportages de nos
correspondants et à nos invités nous
allons d'abord dresser un bilan de la
situation et puis nous allons tenter de
comprendre comment l'afrique va
continuer à se développer tout en tenant
compte de ces donne environnementale
[Musique]
nous sommes à proximité d'un des projets
les plus emblématiques de cette afrique
qui se développe et qui s'adapte à
l'environnement il s'agit de l'échangeur
géant de coucou ainsi financé par la
banque africaine de développement cette
infrastructure routière a pour objectif
d'augmenter la productivité de la
capitale ghanéenne tout en réduisant la
pollution et la pollution de l'air pour
en parler nous sommes avec notre invité
chila hachey là elle est ingénieur
chargé des infrastructures routières à
la banque africaine de développement
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ici pour
parler de ce projet tout d'abord
pouvez-vous nous décrire ce projet
c'est un échangeur à quatre niveaux une
voie centrale de look et une bretelle
surplombante il ya aussi cette forêt
sacrée que l'on à protéger une source
d'eau pour les riverains nous avions
aussi prévu des tranchées d'évacuation
pour éviter des inondations dans cette
zone on récupère l'eau stagnante pour
évacuer vers la rivière avoisinante qui
est une rivière sacrée
ce projet réduit les émissions de co2
dans la zone et réduit les temps de
trajet avant il y avait des bouchons de
plusieurs kilomètres maintenant ça ne
prend que quelques minutes pour
traverser la zone
ça réduit les coûts d'entretien des
voitures car la route est en bon état et
ça a vraiment booster l'activité
économique de la zone
comment ce projet s'est adapté à
l'environnement
l'accès à la zone était très difficile
il cette zone devait s'ouvrir au
développement
quand le projet d'échangeur de pau
kouassi a commencé on a tenu compte de
l'environnement dont la forêt ça crie
qu'il fallait préserver
on a fait en sorte que les plans de
l'autoroute s'adapte à l'environnement
l'améliorer projet a changé concrètement
dans la vie des gens ici au ghana
si vous aviez vu cet endroit avant vous
vous rendriez compte que toute la zone a
été bouleversé les habitations ont pris
de la valeur parce que l'endroit est
plus facilement accessibles
les accidents diminue
les gens peuvent se rendre dans le
quartier d'affaires en quelques minutes
au lieu de rester coincés dans les
bouchons pendant des heures
les élèves sont à l'heure à l'école
cette route relie accra au nord du ghana
et ça permet de transporter les
marchandises vers le nord du pays achat
sporting goods
merci beaucoup au chili qui a donc
chargé des infrastructures routières à
la banque africaine de développement
merci infiniment
[Musique]
pour réduire la pollution il y à
d'autres moyens et le rwanda un pays qui
est devenu un modèle sur le continent en
matière environnementale a opté pour
l'électrique mais le pays qui a déclaré
la guerre au sac plastique depuis plus
de 14 ans a décidé là aussi de
poursuivre sur sa lancée reportage de
notre correspondant à kigali simon
veulent voir
[Musique]
le rwanda pour objectif de devenir plus
vert les autorités encouragent les
chauffeurs de taxi à passer à
l'électrique régis a franchi le pas il
ya quelques mois oui mais là il nous
montre le fait que cette moto est moins
polluante m'a motivé en avoir
l'intérêt est aussi économique
je gagne aussi beaucoup plus d'argent je
dépense moins pour les réparations
qu'avec une moto essence et maintenant
l'état cité à moins cher que le
carburant le gouvernement souhaite que
30% des motos taxis pasta l'électrique
d'ici 2030 mais le chemin est encore
long aujourd'hui moins d'un millier de
véhicules sont dotés d'une batterie sur
un parc de 26000 de roue pour les
déchets le défier tout aussi important
en 2019 le pays a interdit les
plastiques à usage unique une loi pas
encore totalement appliqué ces
bouteilles plastiques qui sont bannis
pas la loire et le pays a accepté que si
on pète nouvelle date est natif de
l'équipe nationale de l'eau s'éclate
dans le sillage on peut laisser utiliser
ces bouteilles
pour l'instant l'entreprise compresse
ces bouteilles pour les stocker en
attendant de trouver des débouchés
économiques pour ce produit
le ronde à sa fiche en tout cas comme un
pionnier sur le sujet à l'international
cette année le pays a porté une
résolution à l'onu avec le pérou sur la
pollution plastique sont revenus un
match était un despote lorsque vous êtes
une telle loi il ne s'agit pas seulement
de lutter contre la pollution
elle a aussi pour but de trouver des
solutions alternatives de réfléchir aux
technologiques doivent être mises en
place
enfin elle s'attaque également aux
financements nécessaires
pour que les pays mettent en oeuvre ce
type d'instrument des scans de même le
ronde a pour objectif de réduire ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 38%
d'ici à 2030
[Musique]
du baiser qu'elle est notre invité dans
cette émission spéciale vous êtes
activistes ghanéen est lauréat du prix
goldman pour l'environnement merci
beaucoup d'être ici avec nous on l'a vu
dans le reportage précédent certains
optent pour l'électrique pour combattre
contre la pollution la pollution de
l'air vous vous avez mené une autre
bataille vous l'avez remporté une
bataille contre le charbon
je suis un activiste pour le climat
défenseur des énergies vertes comme
antonin 2016 le gouvernement du ghana a
proposé de construire une usine de
charbon pour résoudre notre crise
énergétique et créer des emplois pour
les jeunes mais nous pensons que ce ne
sont pas de bons arguments et que ce
type de projet n'est pas souhaitable à
cause des émissions des usines de
charbon et de leurs conséquences sur la
santé des riverains
nous pensons qu'il est préférable
d'investir dans les énergies
renouvelables plutôt que dans le charbon
c'est pour cela que nous avons milité
contre le projet d'une usine à charbon
et le gouvernement nous a écouté
et applaudi ce n'était pas si difficile
on avait établi un plan pour la première
étape c'était la stratégie
du sous marin on n'a pas fait de
campagne publique pas de manifestation
on a fait des recherches et poser des
questions autant on est allé voir les
communautés locales on a parlé à leurs
chefs aux anciens aux groupes de femmes
as pour obtenir leur soutien
s'est aussi tournée vers des ong
d'autres pays d'afrique pour avoir assez
d'informations pour étayer nos arguments
et ne pas être dans l'émotion 2 on a
besoin de
rester avec nous je vous emmène à
présent à kinshasa en république
démocratique du congo avec ses 15
millions d'habitants la capitale
congolaise est la troisième plus grande
ville d'afrique elle produit près de 10
mille tonnes de déchets par jour moins
de 10% de ces déchets sont recyclés ou
trier et ses déchets qui nie
systématiquement déversés dans les cours
d'eau est le fleuve congo il y a très
peu très peu d'études scientifiques qui
mesurent l'étendue de la pollution de
ses eaux mais des chercheurs congolais
se battent chaque jour pour alerter
l'opinion publique
reportage de clément boudreau et julien
dubois
pour le professeur céline paul et
spécialiste des rivières à kinshasa les
descentes sur le terrain sont toujours
un spectacle affligeant
a mené les matières fécales ça débouche
vers le fleuve directement l'exutoire
c'est le fleuve congo à travers la ville
ces mêmes scènes déchets organiques
plastique et industriels envahissent les
cours d'eau l'équipe de chimistes
effectue régulièrement des mesures pour
déterminer l'impact de cette pollution
sur l'environnement là nous sommes en
train de suivre
l'oxygène voyez ça baisse très vite dans
les concentrations inférieures à 1 ça
veut dire que il ya une asphyxie a
pratiquement billes aura pas moyen que
le poisson puisse vivre ici une
catastrophe écologique qui présente
aussi des risques pour la santé à
l'université de kinshasa des analyses
plus poussées ont révélé la présence de
substances dangereuses dans les rivières
des bactéries responsables de maladies
des antibiotiques et même des métaux
lourds comme le plomb et le mercure
certaines se retrouvent même dans l'eau
consommée par les kinois comme l'a
montré une étude publiée en novembre
davantage de faire de sensibilisation
pour que les populations comprennent que
les leurs activités impact sur la santé
publique
la ville de kinshasa elle dit vouloir
faire de l'assainissement sa priorité
une usine de recyclage des déchets
plastiques d'une capacité de 50 tonnes
par jour a été inaugurée en avril et une
station d'épuration des eaux usées
devrait ouvrir ses portes dans les
prochains mois mettant justement
l'accélérateur sur la construction des
décès centre d'épuration d'eau je pense
qu'on était d'ailleurs on va finir la
première en tout cas phase ce site va
être peut être opérationnels qui je suis
convaincu qu'à partir du moment où nous
voyons ces déchets comme une matière
première comme une ressource la ville va
se nettoyer par elle même et ce sera
automatique environ dix mille tonnes de
déchets sont produits chaque jour à
kinshasa moins de 10% sont ramassés par
la ville
[Musique]
jb zibouh vous même vous êtes un
activiste vous avez mené des combats et
on s'est rendu compte que les petits
combats sont aussi importants que les
grands est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça la peau comment les gens doivent
s'impliquer parce que ça les concerne
directement ça concerne leur propre
santé
quand on sensibilise les populations et
qu'on les pousse à participer elle se
mobilise les riverains pour ramasser les
déchets sur la plage et ainsi contribuer
à éviter des maladies comme le paludisme
et le choléra donc oui ces initiatives
sont très importantes
merci vont coûter bézy et ezequiel en
tout cas vous le prouver vous que ces
initiatives ces petites initiatives
peuvent devenir importante pour pour
l'environnement merci infiniment d'avoir
répondu à nos questions comme vous le
voyez nous nous trouvons près des côtes
ghanéennes ces belles côtes qui sont de
plus en plus menacées par l'érosion
selon l'unesco 37% de ses terres
côtières orientale du ghana ont été
perdus à cause de ce phénomène au
sénégal c'est la mangrove qui est menacé
selon l'onu 40% de cette mangrove a déjà
disparu en raison de la sécheresse et de
la déforestation les autorités
sénégalaises ont décidé de lancer un
projet en étant à contribution des
femmes cueilleuses d'huîtres reportage
de sarah sakho elimane dao
sur un îlot au coeur de la mangrove ces
villageois installe des guirlandes à
huîtres des collecteurs qui vont
permettre de recueillir les naissains
ses larves qui circulent en abondance
dans les eaux saumâtres
le travail est rude mais plus lucratif
que la simple que y est pratiquée
traditionnellement dans la région quand
on recueille les huîtres on les vend au
marché l'argent récolté me permet
d'aider mon mari n'en les dépenses
quotidiennes et d'acheter aussi des
fournitures scolaires pour mes enfants
le gars ce projet vraiment très
avantageux pour nous les femmes sommes à
quelques 200 ostréicultrice sont ainsi
été formés dans la région en trois ans
par le fida le fonds international de
développement agricole
grâce à cette reconversion les femmes
n'abîme plus la mangrove en coupant les
racines des palétuviers où se fixent les
huîtres sauvages mais madou barhoum qu à
demi siècle on empêche les gens à
rentrer dans la mangrove pour couper en
mettant des barrières donc c'est un gros
serveur a fermé l'accès
mais en même temps à proposant une
alternative deuxièmement vous voyez les
pages comme toulon
ces deux localités
processus
dont le ciné saloum c'est l'essentiel de
la population qui vit des ressources de
la mangrove cette surexploitation mais
également la baisse de la pluviométrie
et la montée du niveau de la mer sont
autant de dangers pour ces zones humides
pour les préserver il faut donc replanté
sur cinq hectares les villageoises
reboise les arbres disparu l'enjeu est
de taille selon cet expert dès que vous
supprimez martin ponsâa dès que les eaux
également voilée directement comptine ah
bon ça lui misé les terres agricoles ça
va augmenter la pauvreté la faim selon
un rapport des nations unies la mangrove
et détruites jusqu'à cinq fois plus
rapidement qu'une forêt traditionnels
alors pour protéger cet écosystème est
extrêmement fragile les initiatives se
multiplient ici au sénégal dans le delta
du saloum mais également au sud du pays
dans le grand delta de la casamance
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
spéciale environnement tourné au ghana
merci à notre chef d'édition célia
karacena merci à toute l'équipe qui a
contribué à retourner cette émission
spéciale restez avec nous l'info
continue sur france 24
[Musique]